The w unit tells the browser
the dimensions of an image file so
it can make a sensible choice
about which image to retrieve.
But what if the image isn't displayed
at 100% width of the viewport?
Well the browser parses the HTML and
starts image pre loading
before the CSS is parsed.
And at that point, it knows
nothing about image display sizes.
Here's where the sizes
attribute comes into play.
The sizes attribute tells
the browser the sizes at
which an imageswill be displayed.
So while parsing the HTML,
the browser can work out
which image file to request.
In theory,
the browser cou'd get this data from
CSS, but CSS parsing comes later.
Adding the sizes values to HTML ensures
the browser can fetch images as soon as
possible, the right image for
the right image display size and
device capabilities.
And just to be clear,
the sizes attribute does not
actually resize your image,
you still need to do that in CSS.
Okay.
Remember our source set example for
w units.
Well let's resize our wallaby.
Now she's 50% of viewport width.
Let's take a look at
the network request for that.
You'll see that even at
the smaller window size,
the browser is still getting the medium
image, which is larger than you need.
So let's work it out.
The window is 400 pixels wide, so
the image will be displayed at
half that width, 200 pixels wide.
We're on a 2x display.
so we need an image at least
400 pixels wide to look okay.
Now our small image, which is 500
pixels wide, should be fine, got that?
Okay, so at the time
the browser fetches the image,
it doesn't know anything about
the display size of the image.
So it defaults to assuming the image
will be the full width of the viewport.
So, let's add a sizes attribute,
reload, and see what happens.
The small image is downloaded.
The sizes attribute here
is telling the browser,
this wallaby will always be
displayed at 50% viewport width,
and, given the files available,
please choose appropriately.
What if you want different image display
sizes at different viewport sizes?
Well, the sizes attribute really comes
into its own with media queries.
That wallaby was getting a bit too big,
so let's put a limit on the width.
Now, in this example,
we've set our wallaby to display at 100%
viewport width, at viewport
widths of 250 pixels and less.
And 50% viewport width above that.
Notice how the sizes attribute
corresponds to the CSS.
Just to reiterate, the sizes attribute
tells the browser at HTML parse time,
what the image display width will be.
It doesn't actually affect
the display size of the image.
And by the way,
I've added a CSS transition, so
the size change isn't too jarring.
Just because I felt like it.
You can get the actual source chosen for
an image using the image's
currentSrc property.
Make the window bigger and ta-da,
you can see that the image
has a different source.